يحذرون من مخاطره ويقارنوه بالاسلحه
النوويه والجوائح واللحظات الاولى لرائده
الفضاء السعوديين على الارض بعد المهمه
التاريخيه وفي الاردن انطلاق الاستعدادات
الاخيره للزفاف الملكي وبدء وصول المدعوين
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
الذكاء الاصطناعي الواحد حاسس كانه فجاه
العالم صحي على انه في ذكاء اصطناعي لانه
فعليا في كميه اخبار وتطورات لهذا الخصوص
يوميا بشكل غير طبيعي وكل عناوين رئيسيه
في الاخبار ومن بعد ما سمعنا اصوات معارضه
للذكاء الاصطناعي ومحذره منه سواء من عموم
الناس او من مختصين في التكنولوجيا الايام
الماضيه بدانا نسمع تحذيرات من نوع مختلف
تحذيرات هذه المره طالعه من اهل الذكاء
الاصطناعي نفسهم مجموعه من اهم خبراء
الذكاء الاصطناعي في العالم بالاضافه
لشخصيات مرموقه ومعروفه اصدر بيان وتحذير
جديد من مخاطر
التحذير مو مثل ما سمعنا قبل انه راح ياخذ
وظائفنا او يصير اذكى مننا هذه المره
التحذير وجودي الجماعه بيقولوا انه في خطر
انه الذكاء الاصطناعي يسبب انقراض البشريه
يعني متخيلين حجم اللي جالسين يعني بنتكلم
عنه
كله على بعضه كان جمله واحده وهي التخفيف
من مخاطر انقراض البشريه بسبب الذكاء
الاصطناعي لابد ان يكون اولويه
عالميه مثلها مثل مخاطر الجوائح والحرب
النوويه يعني انتم متخيلين بقارنوا ايش
بايش البيان موقع عليه عدد كبير من
الخبراء والشخصيات المعروفه من صناع
التكنولوجيا ومنهم عن الرابط ذكاء
الاصطناعي وسام التمان رئيس الشريك او
رئيس
جوجل ديب مايند ورئيس التكنولوجيا في
مايكروسوفتن تحديدا وهو على الرابط الذكاء
الاصطناعي زي ما قلت لكم مشاهدينا في
العالم ومن روادو كان استقال من جوجل من
فتره بسبب مخاوفه من خطوره الذكاء
الاصطناعي ومن ايام كمان قبل البيان طلع
وحذر وقال انه الاي اي بيشكل خطر وجودي
على البشريه
اخذت
انه يحل مكان الانسان في عده مجالات وانه
يقضي على وظائف بعدين صار في كلام عن انه
راح يصير اذكى من الانسان والمخاوف الاول
كانت من ناس عاديه او ناس متشائمه عموما
ومعاديه للتكنولوجيا لكن بعدها صرنا نشوف
خبراء المجال نفسهم هم اللي جالسين
بيتكلموا فطلع بيان عن الاف الباحثين اللي
هم دعوا لوقف مشاريع تطوير انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي الكبرى لمده سته اشهر شفنا كمان
اللي كان من مؤسسي اوبن وبيحذر وغيره كمان
حتى شفنا اتكلموا في هذا الموضوع اليوم
نفس جماعه الذكاء الاصطناعي واهله بيحذروا
فايش الحقيقه هل فعليا في تهديد بانقراض
البشريه بسببك الاصطناعي يعني احنا عدينا
تسونامي وحروب او كورونا طبعا حيجي الذكاء
الصناعي هو اللي حيجيب اخرتنا وحيسبب
انقراض البشريه
كريم فريد المختص في التكنولوجيا ومن اكبر
المدافعين عن
حيرد على هذه الاسئله المره دي ما لازم
يعني دفاعك لازم يكون متوازن ليش لانه اول
كنا بنتكلم ناس العاديه خايفه اول شيء
عادي كده الامور الان نفس الناس اللي هم
بيشتغلوا في الايه اللي مالكين هذه
الشركات هم بحذروا مبدئيا البشريه ممكن
تنقرض بسبب
سبب غباء بسبب حاجات كتير قوي
فيعني مش بنفس الذكاء ممكن ينقرضوا بسبب
الغباء كمان مش ده السبب الوحيد ده واحد
البشريه ممكن تنقرض بسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي
هل ده خطر وارد
ممكن في حال تم استخدام الذكاء للصناعي في
صناعه اسلحه بيولوجيه في في صناعه اسلحه
نوويه تطوير اسلحه في اطار التسليح ولكن
انقراض البشريه
الاسلحه موجوده انت بتتكلم مثلا تمكين
وجودها عند افراد او مجموعات او او ان هو
يتم استخدام لان الذكاء الاصطناعي ممكن
يساعد في تطوير مثلا ان في الاربعينات لما
اول سلاح نووي او القنبله نوويه العلماء
اللي طوروا القنبله النوويه طلعوا بعدها
واعلنوا ندامهم واستنكارهم ومطالبتهم بوضع
حد لاستخدام الاسلحه النوويه ونفس الشيء
الاسلحه ولكن عشان يوصلوا للقنبله النوويه
الموضوع خد عقود من الشغل للذكاء
الاصطناعي بيقدموا النهارده ان هو يقدر
يختصر العقود لسنين قليله وهنا ده الخطر
كل الناس متخوفه منهم فهل من الضروري ان
يكون في تقنين
وتحجيم للاستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي في
اطار صناعه الاسلحه او لاي استخدامات خطره
مع مليون في المئه
وتشريعات ومعاهدات الحد من الاستخدام او
من سوق الاستخدام للذكاء الاصطناعي من
افراد او مؤسسات بيهدفوا ان هم يضروا
غيرهم لا بالعكس انا مع الموضوع جدا
فعاله يعني احنا بنتكلم على تكنولوجيا في
يد الناس خلاص ادهنها النقطه التانيه هنا
ان احنا دي تكنولوجيا او الاستخدام
المتطور جدا من الذكاء الاصطناعي في
مساحات محدده ومساحات خطره خطره سواء
باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي او باستخدام ان
واحد يحاول يعمل سلاح في البيت او ايا يكن
فهنا هي خطره في كل الاحوال ولكن
استخدامات الذكاء الاصطناعي المفيده
للبشريه كتير جدا حرفيا لا تعد ولا تحصى
فبالتالي انا ما ينفعش انا مع وجود
التشريعات ولكن مع في نفس الوقت الدفاع عن
حق الناس من الاستفاده من التكنولوجيا
الحديثه ما ينفعش نمنعها ما ينفعش نقول
العربيه والله ممكن تموت واحد فخلاص نلغي
العربيات ونرجع نمشي بلحصنه اصلا يعني زي
ما بيقولوا انه خلاص القنبله انطلقت او
السفينه انطلقت يعني خلاص بدا المشوار
الذكاء الاصطناعي موجود يعني بس لما يجوا
اللي هم الكبار في هذا المجال ويقولوا يا
جماعه حتنقرض البشريه بسببه هم بس
بيتكلموا عن مخاوف من موضوع السلاح وكده
ولا الموضوع لما بيقولوا خطر وجودي هو
بالتاكيد الخطر الوجود
تعترف انا اللي بحسه تعرف يا كريم بحس انه
هم في شيء يعرفوه ولا شافوه وما قالوا لنا
عنه ممكن ما اعرفش بس اللي انا متاكد منه
ان ان اللي اتشات بوط اللي هو بيقعد يرغي
معي دوت اكيد مش هيقدم الانقراض البشري
دوت واحد صاحبي قاعدين على قهوه
لانه بنساله اسئله احنا حديث غبائهم
بالضبط هو هيبطل مع الوقت نقطه ولكن مش ده
اللي هيقدم الانقراض البشري الحيادي
الانقراض البشريه هو حاجات متطوره اكتر
بكتير ولكن لو انا بتكلم بجد هو هنا زراعه
او ان احنا نحط المخاوف ممكن يكون صحي في
مرحله ما عشان نقدر تاني نمنع الاستخدامات
السيئه ولكن في اطراف تانيه لهم اهداف
مختلفه مثلا ان اكبر صراع حاليا يبقى او
الصراع المحتمل القادم هو الصراع ما بين
امريكا والصين على تايوان ليه لان تايوان
هي اكبر بلد بتقدر ان هي عندها قدرات
تصنيع الرقائق الالكترونيه المتخصصه في
الذكاء الاصطناعي وهنا ده من السبب من اهم
اسباب
التنشن ما بين
الصين وامريكا فهنا في صراع على مين يملك
التقنيه ومين يقدر يحجم ويسيطر عليها
ويمنع غيره من استخدامها وعشان كده نشوف
هي مثلا شركه اللي هي كانت بمتخصصه في
صناعه رقائق الكترونيه للاجهزه المستخدمه
في الالعاب دلوقتي دخلت في عالم الاي اي
بشكل كبير عشان ان امريكا تقدر
توطن نقدر نقول صناعه الرقائق وبالتالي في
الحاله دي تقدر تستغنى عنوان وتقدر تمنع
او تمنح
حلفائها
ادي حروب حتدخل فيها دول يعني وحكوماتها
وهي بالفعل قائم نحن بنشكرك على وجودك
معنا اليوم كان معنا كريم فريد المختص فيه
تكنولوجيا شكرا لك
اهلا من جديد لحظه تاريخيه شاهدها
شاهدناها جميعا يعني فجر امس مع انتهاء
مهمه الفريق السعودي الى الفضاء وعوده
ريانه بالسلامه الى الارض من بعد عشره
ايام في الفضاء شاركوا فيها بعدد من
الابحاث والتجارب العلميه المختلفه وحتى
في حلقتنا امس تابعنا على الهواء مباشره
انفصال مركبتهم عن محطه الفضاء الدوليه
وبعدها هبطوا في سلام مراحل معقده ومقاطع
كثيره شفناها من امس وحقيقه يعني بتطرح
تساؤلات كثيره عن صعود المركبات للفضاء
وعودتها فخلونا مشاهدينا نستعرض المقاطع
مع بعض ونحكي عن هذه المراحل علي وريانا
بعد ما خلصوا ايامهم ومهمتهم في الايه صار
لازم يرجعوا واول شيء شفناهم في فيديو
وداعي شكروا في رواد الفضاء اللي لسه
موجودين في محطه الفضاء الدوليه ومن بعدها
تابعنا ركوبهم في مركبه دراغ اللي ملتحمه
مع المحطه واللي كانوا طلعوا فيها اصلا
للفضاء وبعدها تابعنا انفصال المركبه عن
المحطه وحتى هذه اللقطات كانت امس
بالتزامن مع حلقتنا وشفناها على الهواء
مباشره سوا بعد الانفصال المركبه الجلسه
في طريقها للارض 12 ساعه من بعدها بتبدا
مرحله خطيره تانيه وهي ايش مرحله دخول
الغلاف الجوي المركبه دراغون دخلت الغلاف
الجوي وكانت حقيقه لحظه يعني بتحبس
الانفاس احنا بنتكلم عن مركبه سرعتها سبعه
كيلو في الثانيه يعني
في الساعه فعليا لحظه الدخول هذه بتخلي
المركبه تظهر في الجو وكانها شهاب او كذا
جرم سماوي وهذا الفيديو اللي شايفينه
امامكم نزلوا شخص على تويتر ساكن في
فلوريدا جنب المحطه وشاف بعينه دخول
الكبسوله للغلاف الجوي وما كان فاهم ايش
هذا صورها وقال ما اعرف ايش هذا بعد
لما توصل المركبه على الارتفاع خمسه كيلو
متر ونص عن الارض بيطلقوا فراشوتين لتخفيف
سرعتها وعلى ارتفاع 2 كيلو متر بيرجعوا
بيطلقوا اربعه برجتات تانيين بزياده يعني
وبتتجه الكبسوله الى مكان الهبوط في
المياه اللي بيكون طبعا هذا المكان تم
اختياره من قبل او من قبل يعني تحديدا
بيكونوا اختاروه من بين عده مواقع هبوط
ودائما بيكون في موقع هبوط اساسي وبيكون
في واحد كمان بديل في حال اي طارئ
والاختيار طبعا هذا بيتحكم في عدد من
العوامل فمثلا منها طبعا الاحوال الجويه
وعوامل كثير ثانيه الكبسوله لما بتقرب من
المياه عشان تهبط بتكون سرعتها نزلت ل 27
كيلو متر في الساعه وطبعا في المياه فرق
ناسا وسبيس اكس بتستنى الكبسوله هذه فرق
مدربه على كل السيناريوهات الكبسوله هبطت
واستقبلتها الفرق وسحبتها للسفينه اللي في
المياه اصلا علشان ينزلوا منها
كلنا بعدها كنا بس نبغى انه يفتحوا الباب
ونشوف علي وريان وزملائهم لكن شفنا فرق
الارض وهي جالسه بترش ماء على باب
الكبسوله وبعدها بتطلع وبتنزل وبتفحص وللي
بيسال هذا ايش هذه خطوات مهمه جدا في
عمليه الهبوط فقبل فتح الباب لابد من
التاكد انه الكبسوله امان وانه ما في
غازات متسربه وانه الضغط اوكي تحسبا لاي
حادث عند فتح باباهم وحتى لو تنتبهوا
الطواقم الارضيه لابسه كمامات وزيق خاص
يعني هذا طبعا ايضا برضو وقايه يعني من اي
حادث بعد ما يتطمنوا انه كله اوكي بيخلعوا
اللبس الوقائي هذا والماسكات مثل ما
شايفين وبيفتحوا الباب
في
[موسيقى]
هذا
بعد ما شفناهم بيفتحوا باب الكبسوله
وبيدخلها فريق او بيدخلها بدايه فرق الارض
اللي بيحضروا او بيحضروا حتى هم بيحضروا
كده منحدر لرواد الفضاء وبيبداوا يطلعوهم
واحد واحد وبيساعدوهم طبعا نظرا لانهم
قضوا ايام بدون جاذبيه فممكن جسمهم بدايه
ما يشيلهم يعني
في الفضاء مدد اطول من كده لما ينزلوا
الارض بيشيلوهم بكراسي وبيقعدوا فتره قبل
ما بيوقفوا على رجولهم مره ثانيه يعني مثل
مو شايفين امامكم الان وبعد وصول علي
وريان وزملائهم بالسلامه وشفنا الاحتفالات
في مركز العمليات الموحد في الرياض
ولحقيقه يعني رده فعله كانت معبره عن رده
فعلنا كلنا بنجاح مهمه ريانه وعلي
طيب الحمد لله رب العالمين من مركز
العمليات الموحد لمتابعه رواد الفضاء
بالرياض وبعد وصول رواد الفضاء قبل قليل
للارض سالمين ولله الحمد وهنئ القياده
وهنئ مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين واسمه
سيدي ولي العهد والشعب السعودي بسلامه
قوات الفضاء وبارك لهم نجاح هذه الرحله
العلميه التاريخيه والتي سترسم في رفعه
الوطن ومكانته في خدمه العلم والابتكار
وخدمه البشريه
ومن ساعات هيئه الفضاء اعلنت الوصول علي
وريان الى مطار هيوستن في امريكا علشان
يبدلوا او يبداوا مرحله التاهيل بعد
عودتهم من بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى طبعا من
تفاعلكم بالهني السعوديه بنجاح المهمه
وعوده علي وريانا بالسلامه وكذا بالنسبه
للستار على اول مهمه علميه سعوديه الى
الفضاء مع اول رائد فضاء سعودي بيوصل
لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه واول رائده فضاء
عربيه مسلمه
رسائل ويجري مثل ما نشوفه في الارض
اللون الاخضر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يوم واحد بيفصلنا عن الزفاف الملكي
الاردني المنتظر زفاف ولي العهد الامير او
العهد الاردني الامير الحسين من السعوديه
رجوى السيف والتحضيرات والتجهيزات للزفاف
خلاص في مرحله اللمسات الاخيره وضيوف
الزفاف بداوا بالتوافد من مختلف دول
العالم اليوم الملك عبد الله بيقيم مادبه
عشاء لاربعه الاف شخصيه اردنيه وبكره رح
تتم مراسم عقد القران في قصر زهران بعدها
بتنطلق مسيره الموكب الملكي الاحمر اللي
راح يجوب شوارع عمان اللي تزينت بهذه
المناسبه وراح يمر بالسبع مواقع مخصصه
للاحتفالات وصولا الى قصر الحسينيه اللي
راح يكون في العشاء وحفل الزفاف وللي
بيسال ايش الموكب الملكي الاحمر فهو تقليد
ملكي عريق موجود من وقت تاسيس الدوله
وبيتكون من عشرين سياره حمراء مكشوفه ذات
طابع كلاسيكي 14 منها بتستخدم في الموكب
وفي ست احتياط وبترافقها دراجات ناريه
وبيستقلوا 71 فرد من الحرس الملكي بيلبسوا
اوشحه حمراء على صدورهم ولباس الجيش
والكوفيه الحمراء وهذا الموكب عاده يستخدم
في الاعياد والمناسبات الوطنيه مثل عيد
الاستقلال وخطاب العرش السامي واي زفاف
ملكي وكانت بدات بروفات مسيره الموكب
الاحمر في شوارع العاصمه من امس
[موسيقى]
وكمان من بين التحضيرات ومظاهر الاحتفال
بوليه العهد الاردني الاغاني اللي لا زالت
مستمره واللي كثير من الفنانين العرب
اهدوها للامير الحسين والانسه
[موسيقى]
مبروك
الامير قلوبنا
الهاشمي والركبينا الحالي نمشي على هقويتك
يا حلمانه وانت العالي بتستاهل والحاضر
وانت العادي
[موسيقى]
والحاسديننا يا الكفو معك الشاعر فيلا
عبد الله
الورد والحنه على
عروسنا يا ولي العهد حنا بك مرفوع عروسنا
ويا بين واشرف العرب بين اسياد القوم رجوى
القلب المثلى ما بيتلاقوا كل يوم
لنا كل مكان ليلي ست العواصف
اتزينك هاتوا الحبايب كلهم والعربي كبير
فرحتهم الاردن رجال وبواسل الملك عبد الله
اولهم والمملكه
الهاشميه
حروب
الافراح على العموم مشاهدينا طبعا بكره
اليوم المنتظر واكيد حنتابعوه في امان
الله
يا ابن الحانوت سيدي عبد الله يا ابن
الهوى
[موسيقى]